>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Susan Stamberg:
Morning everybody, welcome,
it's a great day in this city.
First of all, this enormous
celebration of literature and just
across the Mall that
brand new museum opening
for African-American history.
[ Applause ]
I live here so I'm warning you
don't try to go over there today.
It will be so jammed and
impenetrable you'll never make it
but maybe tomorrow or the day after
that's what I'm going to try to do.
We need to thank some people before
we start talking Sharon and I,
first of all of course the Library
of Congress, David Rubenstein
of the Carlyle Foundation,
Carlyle Group.
He's co-chairman of this festival
and of course all the volunteers,
the people, organization who
have supported this festival
over the years.
Some housekeeping we have to do.
Cell phones, you know I forgot
to turn mine off [laughter]
but I'm waiting for
George Clooney to call
so you'll understand won't you
Sharon if we stop in the middle.
>> Sharon Robinson: Well [laughter].
>> Susan Stamberg: Well [laughter],
you know how long I've been waiting
for this and before that
it was Robert Redford.
Anyway, cell phones off please,
we'll have some questions
at the end.
There are microphones around and
you'll need to step up to them
and when you do stand up
straight because they're going
to be filming us so
it's for eternity
or anyway the library's archives.
You want to look good.
I think we're done.
There will be a book signing.
Sharon will sign books
at 11:30 somewhere
in this vast spectrum
of chairs and tables.
But let's get to the
main event already.
That's Sharon Robinson
and the name of her book
"The Hero Two Doors Down".
Sharon has written a number of books
for young readers and she's created,
this is so interesting to me,
a baseball-themed curriculum
for young people for
really self-image right,
a [multiple speakers]?
>> Sharon Robinson: No,
it's actually character
development and good morning.
Thank you all for coming out.
I really appreciate you being here.
[ Applause ]
Yeah, Breaking Barriers: In Sports,
In Life, we're in our 20th year
and it's all about
character education
and helping kids understand
that they.
He told me this was going to go.
My scarf is very fluid and it
doesn't do well with a mic.
Can you hear me?
>> Susan Stamberg: You're okay.
>> Sharon Robinson: Okay, good.
It teaches kids that obstacles
or barriers are a part of life
and we give them values I
associate with my dad's success on
and off the field, the strategies
and ultimately they write an essay
for a contest where they talk about
a barrier they've had to overcome
and how they used the values.
And we get about 17,000 essays
from kids all over the country.
>> Susan Stamberg: Wow.
>> Sharon Robinson: And
then I go out and visit them
and in their schools and
ultimately we bring the top winners
to the All-Star game
and to the World Series.
>> Susan Stamberg: Oh my gosh, 22
million children, young children?
>> Sharon Robinson:
Actually yes, it's actually,
we're up to 20 [inaudible].
Isn't it amazing?
>> Susan Stamberg: It's amazing.
That is quite an accomplishment,
congratulations.
>> Sharon Robinson:
It's a great work.
>> Susan Stamberg: Yeah,
you need to bear with me
because I'm a New Yorker.
I'm also old and I
stopped following baseball
when the Dodgers moved
to Los Angeles.
I was so.
>> Sharon Robinson:
She's not a true fan.
>> Susan Stamberg: I was true.
I was. It broke my heart.
That was the end of everything.
But this book gives me back so much.
>> Sharon Robinson:
Oh good [laughter].
>> Susan Stamberg: Of what the
Dodgers meant and what the city was
like when they had just
arrived and what their future
and the difficulties
especially for your father.
Can you do just a really
quick synopsis of the plot,
that little boy, that young man.
>> Sharon Robinson: Yes, so "The
Hero Two Doors Down" is a story.
It's Steve Satlow's story,
1948 Brooklyn, Flatbush area.
Steve is a big Brooklyn Dodger fan
and my parents moved two doors down.
And so Steve has this, you
know, can't wait to meet Jackie,
can't wait to meet Jackie, all
these missed opportunities,
finally meets him.
But what's interesting is it's
told through Steve's perspective
and what I've loved from my story,
my letters that kids have written me
because Steve is not a perfect kid.
He's like, well, gets
in trouble quite a bit
and so the kids kind of like that.
And what became of Steve and
I said Steve became a surgeon
like he had planned on it but he
did push his 2nd grade teacher
over a hedge when she was
trying to visit his parents.
It's a true story.
So, Steve is alive and we're
good friends and you know,
he just couldn't help but share some
of his very interesting
childhood stories with me.
>> Susan Stamberg: It's
an extraordinary story
because he's a little Jewish
kid, Flatbush in those days
and maybe today still is, was
primarily a Jewish neighborhood
so it interested me why
your parents moved there.
>> Sharon Robinson:
Well, it was actually my,
a black woman purchased the
home in the neighborhood.
My parents just rented the,
one of the flats from her
so it was just coincidence,
it wasn't purposeful.
And they, my parents had never
been around Jewish families either
or the Jewish culture or religion
and so there was some
mishaps particularly
around Christmas and Hanukkah.
>> Susan Stamberg: I think that's
a story that needs to be told.
Will you tell it?
>> Sharon Robinson: Oh yes, okay.
>> Susan Stamberg:
The Christmas tree.
>> Sharon Robinson: Well yes,
well the first Christmas
Steve was over our house.
Now Steve and Jackie had
become friends and Steve is
over at my parent's house
helping my dad decorate the tree.
And at his home they were
preparing for Hanukkah
and neither family conveyed that.
They were preparing
for different holidays.
They were, one was on Saturday
and, Christmas was on Saturday
and Hanukkah was on Sunday,
the first day of Hanukkah.
So Steve just thinks they're.
This is a very cool tree and isn't
it beautiful and then he leaves
and while he's there he asks.
My father asks him
is your tree up yet?
Steve said, well we don't have
one and my father is going well,
why doesn't he have a tree?
It's Christmas Eve, my father after
Steve leaves literally went out
and purchased a Christmas tree,
brought it to Steve's home,
meets Steve's mother for the
first time who is horrified
that she can't tell Jackie Robinson
that she can't accept the tree.
So and then it got even funnier
because like my parents literally
then showed up a little while later
with the ornaments and lights and
to help them decorate the tree.
So needless to say our families
remained lifelong friends.
>> Susan Stamberg: Yeah, yeah but
I love this story, as you do too,
just for what it reveals about
the characters on both sides
and why this friendship began
when Steve was such a young boy
and lasted into today because it's
a kind of caring and thoughtfulness,
a kind of elegance and generosity
and smoothing things
over and going on.
And these were the lessons
that Jackie Robinson brought
to that little boy every
time, every time he say.
You said he was a little bit
naughty, I call it spunky.
I don't know what they
would call it today but.
>> Sharon Robinson:
Teachers call it angry.
>> Susan Stamberg: Yeah, okay,
angry and he was picked on a lot
and there were bullies but your
father helped him with that too.
He gave him some wonderful advice.
>> Sharon Robinson: Absolutely,
there's one particular scene
in the book where Steve has
gotten into a little trouble
on the softball field and he tried
to take on some of the older boys
and he comes home,
you know not wanting
to tell his mother
what had happened,
that he'd gotten into another fight.
And then he sees Jackie and Jackie
goes in the house and comes back out
and now he's gotten the
information from Steve's mother.
You know how the neighborhood
works and so Jackie takes Steve
for a little walk and he says.
And Steve said, well
where are we going?
And Jackie says, we're going
to, I want to see your school.
And Steve knows the boys are still
there so he's a little nervous
but on the way he learns
that he can tell Jackie.
He can be honest about
what happened and you know,
he didn't have to take on.
There's other ways to
work through a conflict.
>> Susan Stamberg: But yes, and
again to me the major lesson,
and such a wonderful one,
was don't get your back up,
especially he was a little kid and
especially with kids who are bigger,
older than you and tougher.
But this is a man, imagine what he
had to go through during his life
and to suppress the true anger
and the real emotions
that he must have felt.
He tells the little boy go up
and say the right thing to them
or say something that reaches a
hand out to them rather than going
like this with your dukes up.
That was.
>> Sharon Robinson: And you know,
what my dad learned very early on is
that there are other ways you can
release that anger and so some
of the great playing you saw
on the field was his, you know,
staying focused, you know
yes holding back that anger
but releasing it as he you know
slammed the ball or stole a base.
In fact my favorite kind of
visual memory of my dad is
when he knows he's got it
and he's going to steal home
and there's just this great
picture of him clapping his hands
and jumping in the air and
taking off and he steals home
and it's like I got this.
>> Susan Stamberg: Yeah, yeah, they
have many lessons for one another.
Steve teaches your father something.
They're in a city after all and
there are brownstones and buildings
with stoops and stuff and Steve
is out there playing stoop ball
and Jackie Robinson says
to him, what's that?
Because why would he know,
right, he didn't grow
up any place with stoops.
>> Sharon Robinson: He
didn't grow up, right.
No, it is a great and you
know it's even funny, Susan,
I had and all of you, you
know I read my reviews
and so I'm reading this review
and it's only a piece
of the review and I go.
And I love it, it's a
great review and I go,
oh I've got to read the whole
review and I go to the whole review
and the reviewer says,
that stickball scene should
have been three pages.
And I go, he's absolutely right, why
didn't we think of that [laughter]?
So I take them very seriously.
>> Susan Stamberg: These
are the [multiple speakers].
>> Sharon Robinson: It reminds
me to slow down you know.
>> Susan Stamberg: Yeah, yeah.
>> Sharon Robinson: Do it right.
>> Susan Stamberg: Right.
But Steve says later that he noticed
how competitive your father was.
>> Sharon Robinson: Oh yes, yes.
>> Susan Stamberg: Learning,
even learning this new sport,
something he didn't know.
Of course he could do it in
his sleep but he saw that.
>> Sharon Robinson: Well that
was important for me to say
because that was part of my
father's character so even at home
if we were playing a family
game of cards after dinner,
I mean my father, it's not like
he held back you know we had
to all compete and you learn
a lot of lessons from that.
So yes, competition was
keen in my dad's home life
and in his professional life.
>> Susan Stamberg: So you wouldn't
take on checkers or Monopoly
and he wouldn't let you just win?
>> Sharon Robinson: No,
absolutely not, we spent many,
a very long day playing Monopoly
and no, he did not let us win.
>> Susan Stamberg: Yeah.
>> Sharon Robinson:
Because that's not like.
>> Susan Stamberg: Yeah.
>> Sharon Robinson: That's
when we started the Breaking
Barriers program, kids,
people used to ask me,
did my dad put the values
up on the refrigerator and I go no.
I learned them just by
watching him and he didn't.
He wasn't a preachy
kind of guy so you sort
of just watched the behavior whether
it's the tough times in our lives
or the joyous moments so.
>> Susan Stamberg: I liked
so much how the two mothers
became very good friends.
>> Sharon Robinson:
Yes, very good friends.
>> Susan Stamberg: And had a
real affinity to one another.
>> Sharon Robinson:
Absolutely, yes Steven's,
my mother Rachel [assumed spelling]
who I had hoped to be here today
but she wasn't able to make it.
She's 94 now, an incredible
94-year-old.
And also you know I have to just
say you know I'm a Scholastic author
and our president of
Scholastic, Ellie Berger, is here
and so thank you Ellie because
it's, you know it's like having.
I'm so lucky to have my Scholastic
family, my baseball family
and my Robinson family [inaudible].
>> Susan Stamberg:
Wow, yes, yes you are.
>> Sharon Robinson: Great
families, great connections.
>> Susan Stamberg: But you were
talking about playing games and all.
>> Sharon Robinson: Yes.
>> Susan Stamberg:
He was away a lot.
>> Sharon Robinson: Yes.
>> Susan Stamberg: He was away
a lot and the family had to deal
with that and I love a passage.
>> Sharon Robinson: Okay.
>> Susan Stamberg: Do you
mind reading a little bit?
>> Sharon Robinson: No.
>> Susan Stamberg: From
your book, I marked it
but you can go on if you like.
>> Sharon Robinson: Alright.
Start with 'Mom'?
>> Susan Stamberg: Yes.
>> Sharon Robinson: "Mom
said that her husband needed
to take some romance
lessons from Jackie".
>> Susan Stamberg: No, no
start over [multiple speakers].
>> Sharon Robinson: It's
Steve's mom, oh, I'm sorry.
>> Susan Stamberg: Oh yeah.
>> Sharon Robinson: She's sorry.
It's like well geez.
Did I write that?
"[Inaudible] I overheard Rachel tell
mom that when Jackie was playing
out of town he wrote her long
letters and sent flowers on Fridays.
Mom said that her husband needed
to take some romance
lessons from Jackie.
The two mothers laughed a
long time over that one.
I told my father about the
conversation between mom and Rachel.
Dad reminded me that since he
worked in Manhattan he didn't need
to write his wife love letters.
I had to agree.
My father worked long hours
but he came home every night.
I counted myself lucky."
>> Susan Stamberg: Yeah.
That little boy is the
narrator of the book.
>> Sharon Robinson: Yes.
>> Susan Stamberg: What was
that like for you as a writer?
>> Sharon Robinson: Well it was.
I thought it was going to be a very
big challenge and I said, okay,
now I'm an eight-year-old Jewish boy
from 1948 Brooklyn,
you know but Steve.
So I went to Steve.
>> Susan Stamberg: Yeah.
>> Sharon Robinson: And we
just, we were still good friends
and we just spent time together
and then I would call him.
I'd go yeah I'm working on a scene.
And he goes, oh let
me tell you something.
Did I ever tell you this story?
So his voice, he's just.
That year was so important
to him that his voice comes,
his eight-year-old, nine-year-old
voice just comes out really strong
and so it helped me tell his story.
So of course I immediately
sent the manuscript to Steve
and his wife Izzy [phonetic].
>> Susan Stamberg: Yeah.
>> Sharon Robinson: And to
Sarah [assumed spelling],
Sarah is now 97 and.
>> Susan Stamberg:
Oh, that's his mother?
Oh.
>> Sharon Robinson: Yeah, yeah so
they called me back and they go.
They loved it so it
made me feel wonderful.
It was a great challenge but
it was also fun to do 1948
because when I first started this
book I thought well what happened
in 1948 you know?
>> Susan Stamberg: Everything.
>> Sharon Robinson: The Dodgers
didn't have a great year.
I was trying to think what was
I going to pull out of that?
And then when you start
doing your research
and you see all these
amazing things.
Women going back, going into the
workforce, more into the workforce.
You know just a change in Brooklyn.
I mean it was all very fascinating
but I came to the part about,
of wanting to do a mitzvah.
I wanted my character
to do a mitzvah so.
>> Susan Stamberg: A good deed.
>> Sharon Robinson: A good deed.
>> Susan Stamberg: A good act.
>> Sharon Robinson:
So I was asking Steve.
>> Susan Stamberg: I love that
she's speaking Yiddish [laughter].
>> Sharon Robinson:
Yeah, well I asked Steve
because you know Steve
is very honest.
Okay Steve, did you [inaudible]?
No. I said, well in
the book you did.
Your character did.
So 1948, it's like okay the
Arab-Israeli War started.
I was like okay.
You've got to have that
in there and so it was.
I had to find an organization
that supported children,
Arab and Israeli children.
It turned out that in 1948 was
when UNICEF was [multiple speakers]
so it was all very fun to put
them together and then to,
so there were creative parts
even though Steve told me many,
many stories.
>> Susan Stamberg: Oh yeah but
also, not just creative but lessons.
I loved the way you moved
history in and out of this story.
>> Sharon Robinson: It's
important to me yeah.
>> Susan Stamberg:
About the little boy.
And you talk about civil rights.
You move all of that in.
You talk about New
York education then,
what all of, what life
was like then.
>> Sharon Robinson:
May I read one quick.
>> Susan Stamberg: Oh
I'd love it, please.
>> Sharon Robinson: Passage that
I'd like to read because when I work
with kids on this book I do a lot
about voice, finding your voice just
for the same reason
we just talked about.
How did I find Steve's voice
and you know and the importance
of having a strong voice.
So there's this scene that I like
to read to them because right now,
I mean many of the issues that are
in this book are contemporary
issues as well.
So, it's before Steve and Jackie
have met and become friends
and Steve's just sort of learning
that this is going
to be his neighbor.
So it's, so his best friend's
name is Seena [phonetic].
They're going out to play.
"An hour later Seena and I are armed
with sticks and a Spalding ball,
rode our bikes to the school yard.
The courts were filled
with other boys and girls.
We joined a bunch of kids from
our school and started up a game.
It felt good to be outside
playing with friends.
We didn't mind the cold air.
Actually it felt good
to run around in it."
"I proudly batted with
my toes pointed inward
like my pigeon-toed
hero, Jackie Robinson.
I wasn't the best hitter
and I didn't run very fast
so the other kids held out
little hope that I'd score.
Still, I swung the
wooden stick so hard
that it grazed the
ball and I got on base.
The rest was easier.
When I got a chance to run I'd
race around bases mustering
in a body warmth to keep me going.
I was all heart."
"Afterward when we were riding our
bikes home Seena told me she had
heard a black family planned
on buying the two-family
house at 5224 Tilden Avenue.
Big deal I told her.
My mom said only Jews should live
in our neighborhood Seena insisted.
Why is that I asked?
Maybe so we can all go to the
same temple she suggested,
or so the neighborhood stays
the way it already is."
"I slammed on the brakes and stared
back at my friend in disbelief.
I'm going home.
What's the matter with
you Seena asked?
The whole talk makes me mad
I yelled as I sped away.
What about a quick game of
stoop ball Seena called?
Not today I yelled back at her.
I didn't understand my sudden
anger but I knew it had to do
with what my friend had said."
"All I could think of was how hard
Jackie had fought his first season
with the Dodgers just
because his skin was black.
Players and fans tried
to make Jackie quit
so they could keep
baseball a white man's game.
Jackie fought back with a well-timed
base steal and a mighty swing."
"I reached home hot and frustrated.
I stomped through the kitchen and
grabbed a quick snack on my way
to my room, trying to
make sense of my feelings.
I pulled out the tin can that held
my most precious baseball cards.
I separated them so the
Dodger lineup was on top.
Jackie was in the mix.
Could Brooklyn win the
World Series without him?
Could they even get back there if
he wasn't on the team I wondered?"
>> Susan Stamberg: That's terrific.
That's terrific [applause].
It's so vivid.
>> Sharon Robinson:
Oh oh, we'd better.
Are you going to let
them ask questions?
We're down to ten minutes.
>> Susan Stamberg: Yeah, okay.
Prepare yourself.
Stand up straight.
>> Sharon Robinson: Thank
you, timekeeper [laughter].
>> Susan Stamberg: Thank you,
stand up straight and come on up
to the microphone [laughter].
But I have more.
Why did you write this book?
Come on up.
>> Sharon Robinson: You know I had
told the book as a part of a story,
that little piece about
the Christmas tree.
>> Susan Stamberg: Yes.
>> Sharon Robinson: In a picture
book and Scholastic wanted to do it
as a middle-grade reader
and I thought.
What I learned in preparing
that Fisher [phonetic] book was
this story had a depth to it
that would be fun to explore for
older kids, that's why, that's why.
>> Susan Stamberg: But I feel that
it has such resonance for today.
>> Sharon Robinson: Today.
>> Susan Stamberg: This morning,
you know this last week our lives.
>> Sharon Robinson: Absolutely.
>> Susan Stamberg:
Because [inaudible] we are
in a tribalistic civilization
these days.
It feels like so many groups are
batting up against one another
and they need lessons like
this from a man like that.
>> Sharon Robinson: But also
it helps people understand
that history is cyclic.
>> Susan Stamberg: Yeah.
>> Sharon Robinson:
We've been there before
and we've had these
battles amongst groups.
We need to fight it
through and get beyond it
and you know someday maybe
we can break this cycle.
It looks like we have
a young Dodger's fan.
>> Susan Stamberg: Oh good, hello.
>> Unidentified Speaker 1: What is
it like to be an author and writing
about one of the greatest
baseball players of all time?
>> Sharon Robinson: Well, you know.
What is your name?
>> Unidentified Speaker 1 Joey.
>> Sharon Robinson: Joey,
I have these huge lights
so I barely see you.
Okay, now I see you.
Joey, I love being a
children's book author.
I think that's what
I should start with.
I've written a couple of adult
books but I really love speaking
to children and I love going
into the schools and going
and having children ask me questions
and us having a discussion.
Now I also have a, my father was
a very special person in my life
and he did teach me lots of
lessons and I just think I learned.
We had so many family stories
that I wanted to share.
So, I have enjoyed
writing family stories.
So I either write about my dad
or I've written about my mother
or I've written purely
fictional books
that have something
to do with my son.
You know, so it's just sort of
fun for me to tell family stories.
>> Joey: Thank you.
>> Sharon Robinson: Thank you.
Do you like to write?
>> Joey: Ah yeah.
>> Sharon Robinson:
And you read as well?
[ Inaudible Response ]
Good for you, keep it up.
[ Applause ]
>> Susan Stamberg: Here's somebody.
>> Unidentified Speaker
2: Do you play any sports?
>> Susan Stamberg: Did you hear?
>> Sharon Robinson: Oh, again a
light, now the light's over here.
Yeah, you know what I
was an all-around athlete
when I was a child all the
way through high school.
My favorites were swimming, ice
skating and horseback riding.
I was a very good horseback
rider and I had a horse.
Baseball was never my best
sport because I wear glasses.
But back then I didn't
like to wear my glasses
so I had a very difficult time
seeing that ball coming close
to me, until it got too close.
So, I would put my
glasses on when it got dark
and then I could hit the ball.
Do you play sports?
>> Unidentified Speaker
2: Yes, I do gymnastics.
>> Sharon Robinson: Oh fantastic.
Did you see the Olympics?
>> Unidentified Speaker 3: Say yes.
>> Unidentified Speaker 2: Yes.
>> Sharon Robinson: Oh well
we had some great young women
that did incredible gymnastics
that won gold medals didn't we?
>> Unidentified Speaker
2: I'm a Level III team.
>> Sharon Robinson: Oh yeah.
Alright, keep it up.
>> Susan Stamberg: Keep it up.
[ Applause ]
Yes?
>> Unidentified Speaker 4: How long
did it take you to write the book?
>> Sharon Robinson: Great question,
how long did it take
to write the book?
It took. We were on a
fast-track as they call it.
So usually what happens is, you
get a contract from your publisher
and I told you I'm
a Scholastic author.
So, they usually give you a
year to 18 months to write
and then they get a year to produce
the book so it's really a two
to two and a half year process.
Some books take longer.
Some books are shorter.
This one, we wrote it in a year
and it was produced
within the two years so.
It takes a full year though.
And you also, I write a
first draft and do my edits.
I may do a thousand edits on my
first draft and then I send it
to my editor and he
sends back comments.
So then I do another draft and then
send it back to him and then we,
you get less comments and then you
finally agree that we're there.
Well we missed that
scene about the stoop.
See we should have made that a much
longer scene so you always learn
and that's what I love
about writing is, you know,
you get better the more you do it.
So when you finish one book and you
learn some of the mistakes you made
in that book you try not to
repeat them the next time.
And that's, you know, same
thing with you in school I hope.
When you get your teacher's
comments, learn from them
because they really help
you become a better writer
and then you can get be
better the next time.
>> Unidentified Speaker 4: Thanks.
>> Sharon Robinson: Thank you.
>> Susan Stamberg: Yes, over here.
>> Unidentified Speaker 5: He
wants to know when you're going
to write your next children's.
>> Sharon Robinson: Ellie, when am
I writing my next children's book?
>> Unidentified Speaker
6: When are you going
to write your children's book?
>> Sharon Robinson:
I'm going to write,
I have already started
working on it.
I can't, you know you're
not allowed to tell a lot
about what it is especially
as I don't have a contract
yet with Scholastic but it will
have something to do with Cuba
and the fact that my mother
and I and we're great.
My mother and I are great
travelling partners.
We've been all over
the world together.
But we had a trip that was
just extraordinary, President
and the First Lady,
President Barack Obama
and the First Lady invited my mother
and I to go with them to Cuba.
>> Susan Stamberg: Oh my gosh.
>> Sharon Robinson: So I really
want to write, share that experience
and also introduce children to a
change in relationship between Cuba
and America and a very
fascinating country.
So, that's, you should hopefully
see that in a couple of years.
>> Susan Stamberg: That's great.
>> Sharon Robinson:
Thanks for the question.
>> Unidentified Speaker
6: Thank you.
>> Sharon Robinson: Okay, bye.
>> Susan Stamberg: I
think we can do one more.
Yes young man?
>> Unidentified Speaker 7:
Good morning to you both.
>> Sharon Robinson: Good morning.
>> Unidentified Speaker 7: My
name is Herb Cowells [phonetic]
and I grew up in New York City and
as a young man my father worked
in Greenpoint, Brooklyn so I
spent many nights at Ebbets Field.
And I also saw your father
play in the 1949 All-Star game
and I will never forget that.
>> Sharon Robinson: Wow
that was his best year.
>> Herb Cowells: Yeah, oh yeah.
>> Sharon Robinson: That's the
year he got the Most Valuable
Player award.
Go ahead.
>> Herb Cowells: Yeah.
I want to hear you speak a
little bit about what it was
like when you went to
see your father play.
>> Sharon Robinson: Well, you
know what, I was so young that.
I was seven when my father retired
from baseball so I really grew
up with him more as an activist
and his baseball career
was something I knew about
and eventually, I didn't.
I really learned more about it
as I started writing
about it for children.
So I remember going
to spring training,
that's what my childhood
memories are and that was
because spring training lasts
for a month and we would go
from Connecticut where
it was cold and snowy
to Florida where I could swim.
So you know as a child you
know what's important to them
but what I also know is that
as a child baseball meant
that he'd be away a lot and so I was
very happy when baseball was over
and we had dad home
at night for dinner.
>> Herb Cowells: Yes, yeah.
>> Sharon Robinson: So it,
so really but I've loved
over the years hearing incredible
stories from men, women who were,
you know, where that was
their Sunday picnic day
or you know they would go to Ebbets
Field or people like you, you know,
that have these wonderful memories
so that is as strong in my head
as the visuals that I've seen
from the [multiple speakers].
>> Susan Stamberg: Thank you
so much for the question.
>> Sharon Robinson: We have
to let this little boy, I.
>> Susan Stamberg: Yeah, one more,
we'll go a little long,
just last question.
>> Sharon Robinson: One question.
>> Unidentified Speaker 8:
Did you know that you were
going to be an author?
>> Sharon Robinson: Oh my
goodness, great question.
I had no idea.
I wanted to be a nurse
when I was a little girl
and that's all my grandmother
said I should ever be in life.
And I became a nurse, midwife and
spent 20 years delivering babies
and teaching women, mostly women, a
couple of men, how to be a midwife.
But in that process
I had to write books
and help students write their theses
because it was Master's level.
It's a long story.
You should never ask a
storyteller [inaudible].
Anyway I always loved to read
so that's what I remember
from my connection to
books was loving to read
and in my house we literally
had a room we called the library
and that's where our
books were kept.
So, books are very
comfortable, books.
I love to write.
I love to read.
And it just, when I started
having to publish as a faculty,
because I was on faculty,
then I started working
for Major League Baseball
and doing a program for kids
and I loved writing curriculum for
kids and I just became a. I said
to Scholastic, well I should
just write a book for kids.
And then once I wrote one book
I wanted to write another one.
And every time I go, oh I'm going
to write an adult book and I go
but I won't be able to see the kids
and so I keep writing
books for children.
Have you ever read any of them?
[ Inaudible Response ]
Have you read any of my books?
Unidentified Speaker 8: Not yet.
>> Sharon Robinson: Well, please
get "The Hero Two Doors Down".
In fact, I'm going to
give it to you right now.
>> Susan Stamberg: Oh,
oh, better sign it.
>> Sharon Robinson: I will sign this
for you as soon as we're over okay.
>> Unidentified Speaker 8: Okay.
>> Sharon Robinson:
Alright, you're welcome.
>> Susan Stamberg: Thank
you for the good question.
Sharon Robinson, thank you for your
books, for your lifetime of service.
>> Sharon Robinson: Thank you.
>> Susan Stamberg: And for
bringing the values of your parents.
>> Sharon Robinson: Thank you.
>> Susan Stamberg: To us and
being so consistent with them
and sharing them so beautifully.
>> Sharon Robinson:
I appreciate that.
>> Susan Stamberg: A pleasure
doing [inaudible] with you.
>> Sharon Robinson:
Thank you so much
for being here with
us today as well.
>> Susan Stamberg: Thank you all.
>> Sharon Robinson: Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov